well it's been another weekend I hope
everybody's weekend was good here in the
United States we had 11 mass shootings
this weekend and more than 300 shootings
altogether those are the right numbers
do not adjust your television do not
punch your phone screen do not throw it
in the toilet and flush it those are the
real numbers 11 mass shootings Friday to
Sunday and more than 300 shootings total
in terms of the mass shootings we had
four on Friday
three on Saturday
and four on Sunday now understand that
in the U.S we have categories of
shootings that don't exist in the entire
world you look at Serbia for example and
what recently happened there with
shootings and you see that there are
categories here that would sound crazy
Elsewhere for example in the United
States we have regular shootings not
mass shootings where one or two people
are killed or injured and many that's a
regular shooting you then have mass
shootings where you have three people
injured or killed in total or more and
then you have
nationally
uh uh covered mass shootings which are
mass shootings that the country takes an
interest in interest in and indeed uh
but by the way if you're interested
about these numbers go to
gunviolencearchive.org you can see the
mass shootings you can see all shootings
over the last 72 hours for example you
know this morning there have already
been shootings in Los Angeles to in
Texas this uh or I'm sorry one in Texas
was this morning one was yesterday okay
so you you kind of get the picture
some of these make National headlines
for example the one in Allen Texas did
this was at the Allen Premium Outlets
where eight victims were killed seven
were injured and the shooter was quote
neutralized for a report by Fox 4 that
one received extensive coverage many
politicians weighing in about it we'll
dig into that one in more detail a
little bit later but then there are
other mass shootings that get less
attention for example there was the one
in St Louis Missouri where two teens
were killed and two others were injured
this was yesterday morning Sunday
morning this one got local coverage but
didn't really get National coverage
that's because in the United States Mass
shoot not just shootings are so common
mass shootings are so common that it's
got to be really depraved and deranged
like particularly sick to even make
National headlines and again that's just
mass shootings then we have just kind of
like your run-of-the-mill shootings for
example these these aren't even a blip
on the radar for most of the country uh
this one was in Pendleton Indiana
where a man was found shot to death and
police are seeking The public's help
this this is sort of like you're more
pedestrian mass shooting for lack of a
better term so this is the day-to-day
reality in the United States and we
continue to have and we're going to
delve into this we continue to have a
political contingent that wants to do
nothing other than offer prayers
sometimes thoughts sometimes they will
think about it but often it's just
they'll pray sometimes thoughts and
prayers sometimes just prayers and uh
when I suggested of course on Twitter
that the prayer doesn't really seem to
help even even Christian schools have
been shot up and certainly there's
prayer happening there I'm the bad guy
rather than all the people who want to
do absolutely nothing we then have
elected officials who choose instead to
focus on Mental Health yet they don't
want to fund Mental Health Services or
they want to focus on violent video
games even when there's no evidence that
the shooter played video games you've
all gotten to know this endless routine
that we have in the United States
another aspect to the cycle of course
the sick Insidious cycle
is right when there's a major again I'm
using the crazy terminology when we have
a major mass shooting of natural
interest National interest we should
have an abbreviation for that uh there
are many people who say now that this is
again in the spotlight as it is every
few days we should really do something
about gun safety laws and these are very
popular proposals we saw even a Fox News
poll last week said that most Americans
favor requiring a background check in
every case of a gun transaction even
between private individuals but these
things are very popular
oh we can't politicize this in the
immediate aftermath tensions are running
High the families haven't buried their
debt you hear all this stuff but we do
send our thoughts and prayers either you
thoughts and prayers you can do at any
time and then a little while goes by and
then hopefully the people seeking to
make change hopefully I mean from the
perspective of the gun people the people
seeking to make change forget or they
move on or whatever the case may be and
then nothing happens and then we have
our next major mass shooting of national
interest and then same cycle over and
over and over again I have to tell you
though we did hear from a few people
after the shooting in Allen Texas who
were stepping out of their you might
call it their prescribed uh characters
and actually said things that make a lot
of sense I want to look at a couple
examples of this uh with you right now
we talked about 11 mass shootings in the
United States over the weekend more than
300 total shootings
those are the real numbers 11 mass
shootings 300 total shootings and much
of what we got from the gun people as I
call them after the Allen Texas shooting
left eight dead seven injured at a mall
much of it was the same do nothing
adject trash that we've been looking at
for decades but we heard from an
interesting guy a witness of the mall
shooting his name is Stephen spanauer
and one of the things that he said was
I'm an ex-cop
I'm an ex-military officer
I'm a gun person I love guns he loves
his guns but he said it wasn't mental
health that killed these people it was
an automatic rifle with bullets this guy
presenting some moral Clarity on this as
a gun lover Okay let's listen I don't
know what the gunman's problem was I
don't know his motive but it wasn't
mental health that killed his people it
was an automatic rifle with bullets
that's to kill him I'm a gun lover I
have guns I'm a former police officer
I'm a former Army officer but these m4s
in AR-15s they've got to get off the
streets or this is going to keep
happening and we've got to stop that at
some point it could be you it could be
your family member I never imagined it
would be me I never imagined it would
happen in my community but it did and we
got to stop this type of Carnage and all
the politicians are going to make
statements they're going to offer
prayers and condolences
won't bring these people back right we
need some action in our legislatures at
the Federal state level for better gun
control I'm saying that as somebody who
loves guns who can argue with that and
you know what this isn't that rare of a
view among the progressive gun owners I
know so many people my age older younger
progressives who own guns and have this
exact same view and to be perfectly
Frank much of their gun ownership this
guy loves guns okay good for him but he
has the clarity to say we've got to do
something about the guns I have some
friends who love guns and collect and
all this stuff and they are completely
fine saying it should be really strict
I'm willing to do whatever I need to do
I'll get the safe I'll get the insurance
I'll get the required I'll get a mental
health eval not that these things are
required but they're willing to do them
if everybody subjected them we'll do the
mental health eval I'll do liability
insurance re-licensing eye exam right
it's got to be at least as difficult as
getting and maintaining a car and a
license on the road uh but some of my
Progressive gun owning friends just
realize that they don't want only the
right Wingers having the guns and that
that becomes a race to the bottom
arguably even though I sympathize with
that and I understand it so we need
something to change that most of us
would agree with although there are some
on the right who actually say we don't
need anything to change other than
buying people buying more guns okay well
they're pretty sick it's going to be
hard to talk to them but we have a list
of very low hanging fruit that the
country by and large agrees with we
looked at the poll last week background
checks in all cases at the top of the
list uh waiting periods Banning some
guns etc etc we can we know some of the
things that the country agrees with but
there's too much money raised there's
too much NRA blood money which is
effectively what it is doled out to
elected officials and unfortunately
listen I don't want to say nothing will
ever change but that's a defeatist
attitude we've seen just about every
scenario teed up where you should be
able to knock one out of the park easily
and and achieve some change after Sandy
Hook comes to mind and yet nothing or
almost nothing happens so good for Steve
spanauer for saying what he said gun
lover but it wasn't mental health it was
the guns that did this meanwhile there
are still Republicans saying all we need
is thoughts and prayers let's look at
that next uh Representative Keith Keith
self is a Republican
he represents the area that uh suffered
this terrible terrible shooting Allen
Texas and he was actually asked on CNN
what about all these people who just say
thoughts and prayers that doesn't work
and he said oh yeah it does you just
have to believe in the power of God what
explain that to me Keith listen to this
now you know Congressman that is a
common refrain after these incidents
after mass shootings but many people
argue that prayers aren't cutting it
prayers are not preventing the next mass
shooting I wish she said she said rather
than many people argue just prayers
don't prevent Massachusetts when you say
many people argue it's like well but
many people argue that they do no it's
just prayers don't prevent mass
shootings and yet it's all you're
willing to offer listen to this what is
your response to that criticism
well those are people that don't believe
in uh
An Almighty God who who has who is
absolutely
in control of Our Lives I'm a Christian
I believe that he is oh we have people
though with mental health that we're not
taking care of since this nation made
the decision that we were going to close
the mental health institutions uh many
of these situations are based on that uh
and the people that say and and I really
I would like to stay away from the
politics today because I want to focus
on the victims right except the problem
is Right Wingers who want to do nothing
always want to stay away from the
politics they are the political problem
right it's it's it's it's almost a sick
joke to say listen this is not about
guns this is about we need mental
institutions which were horrifying by
the way many of the ones that closed
were horrifying I've been reading a book
about it in fact worst conditions
nobody's getting cured at those places
um and but but prayer works but let's
not like get all political I want to
take the politics out of it we could
take the Paul politics out of it if we
just did what the American people agreed
should be done five of the 10 or 12
things that I've outlined before he
makes the political issue a necessity
because he and many of his party say we
don't need anything other than prayer
and I guess mental institutions today
we should be focused on the families oh
uh prayer is powerful in the lives of
those people that are devastated I know
people says who I want to make this
political but prayers are important and
they are powerful in the families who
are devastated right now that may or may
not be
it is completely compatible to say
prayer may be a soothing tool
for victims or it may not it's up to
them
but it has nothing to do with what civil
government must do about this Scourge or
scourge of gun violence depending on
Whose pronunciation you prefer
these can be two different things but
prayer from elected officials certainly
can't be considered policy remember when
a few weeks ago people were furious with
me because I said hey guys if you need
any more evidence that prayer doesn't
work it's that people were shot up at a
Christian School where they presumably
pray all the time and people were mad at
me oh David that's so insensitive you
christian-hating Jew bastard we've got a
lot of those
um how dare you blame the kids
folks the prayer doesn't work that's the
problem whoever thought it did they were
wrong it's not the kids this is really
the offensive thing to say you've just
got to believe in An Almighty God who
controls everything and think of that if
you truly and literally believe
that a God is in charge of the minutia
of everything including mass shootings
why would you legislate anything and
that's the danger that you have to
really understand if we believe Keith
self is literally representing his views
now the prayer is what we need because
God is in control of everything
then of course they're not going to do
anything legislatively they don't think
they have to because God has already
decided how many shootings there are or
aren't going to be and who's going to
survive or die it's a cop-out to do
nothing which is exactly what they've
done so that works really well for them
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com joinpakman.com
the David Pacman show continues to be an
audience funded program may be different
than some of the shows you're used to
watching we don't have a big corporate
funder we don't have a massive ad budget
what we have are people who listen to
the show or watch the show and like it
enough to say hey I'm going to
contribute a few bucks a month that's
really all we're talking about we
provide great perks with great strength
including the award-winning bonus show
it is true it's all Awards we've given
out but still I do think we should
consider them valuable you also get
commercial free audio and video streams
of the show every single day you get
invited to the members only Town Halls
we've got a sound board that you can use
that is a freaking Predator right there
yes on the member side of the website
there's a soundboard you can use for
whatever reasons you might want to use
it I'm not going to give anybody any
ideas and you can sign up at
joinpakman.com always there is a coupon
code available this week you can use the
coupon code indicted indicted let's talk
about the economy starting with jobs we
had very very strong jobs numbers come
out late last week CNBC reports job
growth totals 253 000 in April beating
expectations even as the U.S economy
slows from the standpoint of GDP
the simple facts are non-farm payrolls
were expected at 180 000 came in at 253
000. that's great unemployment rate was
3.4 percent the estimate was 3.6 percent
this is the lowest unemployment rate
since 1969 and average hourly earnings
went up half of one percent and are now
up four point four percent from a year
ago wages growing faster than expected
both in the last month uh and in the
last year a couple of other interesting
things to mention here one is that black
unemployment much touted and discussed
by Donald Trump as one of his major
accomplishments has hit an all-time low
uh do we care specifically about the
racial breakdown of jobs well we care to
the extent that elected officials in
Washington use it as a political
football now what does this say in
general about how the economy is doing
well we have to look at a lot of
different things when we ask how is an
economy doing an economy is not only
jobs an economy is not only stock market
an economies not only GDP or inflation
but in some total we can look at a lot
of these things for example here is a
chart of the Dow Jones Industrial
Average this is a one month chart as you
can see the Dow is up over the last
month here is a six-month chart the Dow
is up over the last six months here is a
year-to-date chart the Dow is up there
here's a one-year chart the Dow is up
there as well and here is a five-year
chart and the stock markets over longer
periods tend to go up and it is up then
as well so jobs numbers quite solid
stock market quite solid inflation
inflation now for the better part of a
year has been trickling down and down
and down with some blips where it goes
up our inflation numbers where we would
love them to be no are they dramatically
better they then when Trump left and Joe
Biden came in absolutely and then we
have GDP GDP growth was still positive
in q1 but it did slow down is this the
most exciting Dynamic and explosive
electrifying economy that we have ever
seen it is not
is this the near disaster that the right
claims the United States economy finds
itself in because of Joe Biden's
presence in the White House absolutely
not and as I've said many times before
many of these indicators only have
little bits to do with the policy from
the Oval Office and the presidency now
there are always reflexive people like
they can't help they just like vomit out
these talking points when they don't
like conceding that the economy is doing
okay because the person they didn't vote
for is in the Oval Office you will hear
things like there's jobs created because
everybody's working two jobs and that
makes the economy bad we have an
indicator of that there are not a
uniquely large number of people working
two jobs at this point in time you hear
about well it's the reason it's
happening is because stay-at-home moms
are having to go back to work because
the economy is so bad uh yet you never
want to talk about that dynamic when you
do your labor participation rate
conspiracy theory so we we hear about
all of these things year in and year out
we can find the data there is not
anything particularly alarming or
different right now about the number of
people who are out of the workforce and
went back in or the number of people
working two jobs it doesn't mean we
don't have problems wages relative to
inflation have been stagnant for a while
now that's a long-term problem it's
bigger than Biden it's bigger than Trump
it's bigger than Obama okay you get the
picture labor participation rate the
country's population has been growing
for a very long time at most times you
can say we have more people than ever
working and we have more people than
ever not working that makes it a really
popular political football to throw
around my suggestion is to zoom out look
at unemployment job creation GDP stocks
inflation meaning Consumer Price Index
wage growth and I could go on a couple
more
and then take the general temperature of
it to get a sense of where we are if you
do that it is not possible to come to
the conclusion some on the right have
come to which is that Joe Biden's
economy is a disaster putting the United
States on the brink of collapse there is
no case that can be made with data
actual data honest data that would
accurately suggest that that is the
situation right now could the economy be
better sure is the economy a disaster
right now not at all could it become one
in the future of course
we have a top rated poll a rated poll
which says that Trump would crush Biden
in 2024 and DeSantis would crush Biden
in 2024. we're going to look at the poll
many of my right-wing friends wrote to
me over the weekend and said David you
will never cover this poll
does that sound like me does that sound
like something I would do just ignore a
poll because the numbers don't coincide
with I guess what I would like the
numbers to say which I would like the
numbers to say nobody's going to be so
stupid that they're going to fall for
voting for Trump again that's what I
would like the numbers to say many of
the numbers don't say that so let's look
at this this new poll and then look at
some caveats Biden faces broad negative
ratings at the start of campaign post
ABC poll finds and indeed we don't have
to look at every aspect of the poll
but when we look at the 538
um a compilation of recent polls and
please there's these people in the
audience who will write to me and say
David why do you use left wing 538 to
look at polls 538 isn't doing their own
polls 5 38 just Aggregates polls so you
can look at the polls and judge for
yourself the deal with the polls okay
ABC News Washington Post poll among
registered voters
Biden losing to DeSantis by six that is
no longer a statistical Dead Heat there
is a caveat and I'll get to it in a
moment among all adults DeSantis leading
Biden by even more seven
what about Biden versus Trump well among
registered voters Trump leads Biden by
six the exact same lead that DeSantis
has and then if you look Instead at all
adults rather than just registered
voters Trump leads Biden by seven the
exact same lead that Ron DeSantis has
over Biden so anytime we get one poll we
usually want to do three things actually
listen it let's be thorough okay it's a
Monday we can be a little more thorough
we want to do four things number one is
this a well-rated poll
or is this a toilet trash pull this is a
this is a well-rated pole a rating ABC
News Washington poll generally speaking
these polls are trustworthy second
question is there something about the
timing of what is being asked about that
would make all polling about this
question less accurate well I don't know
the answer to that you can make the case
it's too early to do general election
polling because it's only May of the
year before but the the the important
thing is if it's too early it's equally
too early for any pollsters so we can
compare this poll to other polls that's
the second question is there something
about the timing or in particular that
would make this a bad time to ask about
this number three are there many
undecideds where you have a lot of
blanks in the polling and the answer is
in this poll we do when DeSantis leads
Biden 44-38 that means 18 of people uh
did not choose either of them they
either said unsure neither don't know
too early to say that's a lot of people
because the the margin is only six so
when 18 aren't even there that's a
that's a question and then with Biden
Trump 16 aren't in there 39.45 you've
got 16 percent of the electorate these
elections come down to somewhere between
one and Five Points in general so yes
that is a big big caveat a lot of people
were not forced into making a choice
here they could say I'm just not sure
yet I don't know someone else and then
the fourth question in general when we
look at polling is
are these polls is this poll an outlier
compared to others and it sort of is if
you look at other polling for example
the b-plus rated yougov poll that was
done just a day before the one I just
told you about that one has Biden
leading DeSantis and Biden tied with
Trump
so the most important message here is
whatever your view on whether you gov
should be a B plus or a B minus poll or
whether the ABC News poll was you know
done at 3am and people were too tired to
respond accurately like whatever you
want to come up with with any of these
polls the message here needs to be it is
not at all obvious
that Joe Biden can defeat DeSantis or
Trump in re-election that's what we need
to be screaming from the rooftops and
that needs to be the message now one bit
of good news from this
is that desantis's numbers against Biden
are good and let me tell you why that's
good news I'll explain what I mean
DeSantis has been crumbling in
Republican primary polls and he had this
bizarre you know where he was asked a
question and he he grinned and was like
a bobble head he was massively triggered
when asked about Trump recently and
we'll have more clips of DeSantis later
today he just doesn't seem to be able to
handle it Republican donors are bailing
on DeSantis billionaires saying this guy
doesn't have what it takes
and so DeSantis it's not clear whether
DeSantis will or won't announce
I believe it is better for the eventual
Democratic nominee likely Joe Biden for
DeSantis and Trump to have a really long
and a really ugly primary I believe that
that will weaken them I don't believe
this well whoever comes out will be
stronger because of the fight no I
believe that many will be turned off by
how ugly DeSantis V Trump is likely to
get and hopefully DeSantis will be
encouraged to run even if he's not doing
so well in the Republican primary polls
because he sees hey if somehow I could
get on the ballot in November of 24 I
have a really good shot at defeating Joe
Biden his ego may not allow him to get
away from running when he sees those
poll results that's the one good bit of
news I can find of them the really
disturbing news is this is a country
who is so disconnected from fact
empiricism Common Sense reality sanity
to some degree that they genuinely might
there's tens of millions of people who
if they get the chance they'll put Trump
in the Oval Office or DeSantis in the
Oval Office and that should really scare
us we'll have all of these stories on
our YouTube channel go to youtube.com
forward slash the David Pacman show help
us get to 2 million subscribers on
YouTube we'll take a quick break and be
right back
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show well the
weird are getting weirder the Donald
Trump said in Scotland that he was
leaving early in order to go to the
Eugene Carroll rape trial in New York
apparently to testify which was news to
so many people wow Trump's leaving he's
going to testify and then he just didn't
then his lawyer said he's not testifying
what are you talking about this just
goes from the comical to the completely
absurd to the pathetic and dishonest
here is Donald Trump trump had until
five o'clock P.M yesterday to let the
court know in writing if he was going to
testify today and he told I believe this
was Irish press I don't know if this
video was filmed in Ireland or in
Scotland here is Trump saying how
terrible it is he's gotta leave early he
could be playing golf you know he's got
to leave early and go testify I guess in
the rape trial that's happening in New
York take a look at this
oh boy
our video is glitching badly that's not
good let's see let's take here we go
leave Ireland and absolutely
we'll have great properties have to
leave early
I don't have to but I choose to will you
attend the trial Mr President it's a
disgrace that it's allowed to happen
it's got false accusations against a
rich guy or in my case against
a famous rich and political person
that's leading the polls by 40 points
right and I have to go back for a woman
that made a false accusation about me
and I have a judge who's extremely
hostile and I'm gonna go back and I'm
going to confront this with this woman
is a disgrace and it shouldn't be
allowed to happen in our country all
right so he very clearly says I'm gonna
go back and I'm gonna confront the woman
and I'm gonna go to the trial okay well
he had up until yesterday at five
o'clock to notify the court that he's
going to do that and of course he's not
going to NBC News Trump won't testify in
E Gene Carroll rape and defamation trial
after judges deadline passes judge Lewis
Kaplan set a deadline at 5 PM Sunday for
Trump to notify the court if he wanted
to testify after his lawyer said that he
would not
so what do we make of it we don't know
did Trump think he was going to go
testify did Trump think the media would
be impressed by him saying he was going
to go his attorneys did not issue a
filing by the 5 PM Sunday deadline that
was set
closing arguments started uh earlier
this morning lawyers for Trump and Carol
rested their case in the Civil Trial
last week Kaplan left open the
possibility for Trump who said he would
not appear to take the witness stand
giving him time to change his mind
Trump's lawyer said last week Trump will
not testify they are not putting on any
Witnesses uh attorney Joe takapina
reiterated that on Thursday when he
rested he told the judge he spoke to
Trump earlier and Trump waived his right
to testify Trump however told reporters
on a golf course in Ireland he was going
back to New York because of the case
I'll probably attend she's a fake it's a
disgrace I've got to go back and do it
so listen I have absolutely no idea
where this case is going to go we're
going to look at
um deposition testimony from Trump in a
in a couple of minutes I have no idea
what this court will find on any of
these questions it has been
obfuscation and chaos and wacky
depositions it's it's been there's no
sensible way
for me to come up with a prediction and
we'll kind of have our answers soon so
so we'll we'll figure that out even
legal opinions that I've looked at are
sort of split as to what is to be
expected here uh what we can be sure of
what we can be sure of is that no matter
the outcome Trump will claim either
Victory or will martyr himself that no
matter what that we know is going to
happen why did Trump say he was going to
testify when he wasn't we don't know
let's now look at what when Trump did
testify in the sense of being deposed
insane videos released over the weekend
all right we have gotten to the end to
some degree of the Trump defamation and
rape trial brought by E Gene Carroll we
now have video of Trump's deposition it
is as crazy as anything I have ever seen
here is a unbelievable moment I would
dare say kafka-esque
Trump has long held one of the reasons
he would not have sexually assaulted e
Gene Carroll is not that he doesn't
sexually assault women it's that she's
not his type
that's about physical attraction
in this video I'm about to play for you
this is unbelievable
Trump is given a picture of e Gene
Carroll and he believes that it's his
ex-wife Marla Maples someone he
presumably was attracted to
completely destroying the notion that e
Gene Carroll is not someone that is
Trump's type he thought it was his own
ex-wife take a look at this I don't even
know who the woman let's say I don't
know who it's Marla
okay it's Marla means it's my ex-wife
Marla Maples
there's like Marvel's in this photo
that's Marla yeah that's that's my wife
which one woman are you pointing each
other now here
's carols
and the person the woman on the right is
your then wife I don't know this was the
picture I assume that's John Johnson is
that because it's very blurry there you
go
Trump insists
by and again I I'm ski I'm not focusing
on the insanity of being accused of
having sexually assaulting someone and
then saying they're not my type
the right reaction from someone who
doesn't commit sexual assault would be
I've never sexually assaulted anyone and
I I don't sexually assault people anyway
it's not his type except it sort of
seems like she was because he thought it
was his own ex-wife that is wild wild
stuff and somehow the people defending
Biden were supposed to believe are
creepy in some way we then get to the
next
um section about this about she's not my
type it wouldn't be my first choice and
Trump I think in this clip he also tells
the lawyer asking him the questions that
she wouldn't be a Top Choice for Trump
either
look at this when you said in that video
that misleads would not be your first
choice you were referring to her
physical looks correct just the overall
not I I look at her I see her I hear
what she says whatever you wouldn't be a
choice of mine either to be honest with
you I hope you're not insulted wow I
would not under any circumstances have
any interest in you
I'm being I'm honest when I say it she I
would not have any interest in when you
grotesque stuff
grotesque stuff Trump wouldn't be
interested in misleads or E Gene Carroll
or the lawyer asking the question he's
just not interested the good news per
Trump is if he doesn't find you
attractive he wouldn't sexually assault
you
of course I would be much more inspired
if Trump were to say doesn't matter how
attractive I find someone I would never
commit an act of sexual assault that's
not what he has chosen to say Trump also
challenged
um the timeline of the infamous Access
Hollywood tape where he talks about when
you're famous they just let you do it
you can grab them by the you know what
Trump asked about whether he was engaged
to Melania at different points in time
and whether that would make that video
more or less problematic or whatever
Trump just basically plays Dumb and says
I don't remember when I was married I
don't remember when I was engaged I
don't know am I correctly that video was
recorded in September 2005.
I guess that would I don't know the date
but whatever date it was is fine with me
and am I correct that you were engaged
to your current life sometime in 2004. I
don't know am I correct that you married
your current wife in January 2005. I
don't know relative to that tape yeah
who doesn't know when he was married now
he's trying to get out of it by saying I
don't know when the marriage happened
relative to that tape
but I mean listen I'm not married don't
most people remember when they got
married is that a crazy thing to think
you would remember I don't know married
people can write to me and let me know
the topic of the Access Hollywood tape
did come up uh multiple times here's
another moment of that in this video
I just started kissing them it's like a
magnet just kiss I don't even wait and
when you're a star they let you do it
you can do anything grab them by the you
could do anything that's what you said
correct well historically that's true
with stars Trump's a historian here
that's all he meant he just meant
from the point of view of a history buff
when you're famous they just let you do
it you can grab them by the you know
what
true stars that they can grab women but
well that's what it's if you look over
the last million years
a million years I have to go back with
that over the last million years 250
000 of which it was modern humans and
then before that even in pre-human times
um you could just that when you were a
star pre-human Stars you know 750 000
years ago they would just let you do it
I it started to I I started thinking to
myself they're talking about stars and
Trump's talking about a million years is
it possible Trump's talking about actual
stars like out in space and this is
actually about something totally
different let's go back uh for the last
million years Trump weighs in on human
history let's listen it's true the stars
that they can grab women but well that's
what it's if you look over the last
million years I guess that's been
largely true not always but largely true
unfortunately or fortunately that's
that's an even crazier little bookend
fortunately or unfortunately I guess it
depends on the eye of the beholder who's
doing the grabbing and who's being
grabbed
for a million years when you're a star
they just let you do it this guy is out
of his mind truly now just for contrast
here's the one clip of this nonsense
that Fox News played which quite frankly
is like they found the only 30 seconds
where Trump doesn't seem as grotesque
listen
I didn't have to reach out to anybody
because it didn't happen
um and and by the way if it did happen
it would have been reported within
minutes
talking about going to a major floor
probably I assume the most important
floor
a major floor in a major department
store that's a very busy store by the
way right and
check out counters and everything else
and I would be in there I mean it's the
most ridiculous it's the most ridiculous
disgusting story it was just made up now
two things one Fox News picking the clip
they skip all the grab them by the you
know what they skipped Trump telling the
lawyer he's not attracted to her which
is crazy
and they picked this one clip where
Trump seems more defiant about just it's
all made up the funny thing is even this
clip isn't that great for Trump if you
understand the full story because Trump
has insisted as part of his defense he
never would really go to that store
Bergdorf Goodman he just he's not super
familiar with it he never went there but
he knows about the crowds and he knows
about which floors are the most
important floors which would have the
biggest crowds even this clip to The
Knowing Observer
contradicts the story Trump has been
telling over and over and over and over
again so the deposition video is Bonkers
cuckoo for Cocoa Puff stuff the both
sides have rested we will see what
ultimately comes of this defamation and
rape trial but if you understand the
back story Trump doesn't exactly look
good here
follow us on social media interact with
the David packman show Community see
exclusive content See when we're taking
calls live and stay up to date on other
Big Show announcements WE Post daily
find us on Reddit Twitter Instagram
Facebook Discord and tick tock
so I hope that by now many of you have
had a chance to see my interview uh with
Lex Friedman on his podcast it's about
three and a half hours long if you
haven't we've linked to it on the Press
page at davidpackman.com you can find it
on Lex's YouTube channel it's on his
audio podcast check it out if it's
interesting to you one of the things
that came up and generated a lot of
discussion is the discussion about
wokeness and to some degree as a
relation in relation to that cancel
culture and I want to delve into cancel
culture here a little bit more because I
think that it has become untenable to
continue even for a second pretending
pretending that the cancel culture is
prevalent anywhere other than the
American right wing now I know that some
of you will say but David hold on a
second it's the right wing that has been
messaging for years now we are against
cancer culture we're against
cancellation we're against all of that
stuff it is the left that cancel cancels
like with most of these things it is the
height of projection from the American
right wing it is they accusing the left
of that which they are guilty of
themselves they say we're against
business regulation we're against it all
except when they want to force Twitter
to publish their covet nonsense all of a
sudden now Twitter should be forced
to publish kova disinformation or
businesses
if you want to require a mask you
shouldn't be allowed to do it new law
you can't require masks if that's what
businesses want to do rather than
letting the free market decide I'm aware
of bookstores that to this day require
masks and I'm aware of people that
choose not to go to those bookstores
because some people are over the masks
that's everybody's Choice nobody's
interfering I thought that was the way
that the right wanted regulation done
okay that gets us to cancel culture
think of the framing from the right
Wingers which is we will not let the
left keep canceling the left or the
cancellers blah blah blah blah blah the
book Banning movement the height of
cancellation growing and growing and
growing and it is the right that is
Banning books which is a form of
cancellation they are creating law
to restrict the phrases terms and topics
that teachers should be allowed to use
or better said should not be allowed to
use that's an insane form of
cancellation they want to cancel Disney
because Disney supported the don't say
gay bill they want to cancel M M's
because one of them was androgynous or
whatever that was crazy they want to
cancel Bud Light because Bud Light did a
promo with a trans woman
and all of it over choices that
businesses are simply making they're not
against the law they don't create any
legal issue
Colin Kaepernick knelt during the
national anthem and then was involved
with Nike they wanted to cancel Nike
because Colin Kaepernick was in a Nike
ad and in fact they wanted to cancel the
NFL at one point because people weren't
standing during the national anthem they
wanted to pull
Public Funding for stadiums the NBA they
wanted to cancel because the NBA has
gone to woke with Dr fauci it's cancel
arrest in prison some even said execute
fouchy execute fauci someone went as far
as to say because fauci
was too arrogant or something about
medical knowledge meanwhile they were
listening to Trump's medical advice Liz
Cheney cancel she's the wrong type of
Republican there's no room for her
cancel her Republican credentials she
can't be in the Republican Party kick
her out other Republicans who simply
don't believe Trump won in 2020 Mitt
Romney cancel him as well they want to
silence people who are woke on Twitter
they want to cancel drag shows that
aren't being forced upon anybody it's up
to parents do you bring your kids to a
drag show or don't you by the way the
other day this is the season now for
Pride parades and I ended up wandering
through a couple Pride parades over the
last few weeks and uh I I laughed to
myself as drag performers came by or you
know what all sorts of different things
I laughed imagine seeing this you know I
had my baby daughter with me imagine
seeing this and thinking oh my goodness
Shield her from this this could this
could damage her this could ruin her in
some way it's Bonkers stuff but they
want to cancel all of it black lives
matter definitely deserves to be
canceled as well
how did these folks become such
snowflakes afraid of everything and
wanting to invoke in so many of these
cases the power of the state the power
of the state not in all but in many of
these cases the power of the state to
control and to cancel as well so we have
to really understand that if you zoom
out I've been telling you for a while
now they've essentially abandoned policy
because they're losing on policy they're
they're running on anti-abortion the
country mostly wants abortion to be
legal their wishy-washy on gay marriage
and sometimes completely against it the
country wants gay marriage to be legal
by a large majority they're running on
don't tax rich people the country by and
large thinks taxing the very rich to
fund social programs is a good idea
they're running on do nothing about guns
when more than 80 percent of the country
says at least pass a background check
law that doesn't let any transaction
circumvent requiring a background check
even transactions between in people who
know each other they're running against
that they're off on all of the policy so
they go well the left wants to cancel
but really it is they who want to cancel
don't fall for it don't fall for it Ron
DeSantis in his latest proof of being
completely not ready for Prime Time
ended up massively triggered at his own
press conference here and we're going to
look at a couple of clips and the story
here is this guy is so not ready or able
to handle a protracted and and ugly
National primary campaign against Donald
Trump he's just not ready uh I don't
know if he ever will be he's so
uncharismatic he's so triglyble that uh
I just don't know that he can ever do it
here DeSantis cuts off a reporter who
tries to ask him about his anti-trans
policies and DeSantis yells out how many
people here are paid or something like
that
how many of these people were paid to
come I mean like honestly it's like
seriously some of this stuff is just
totally manufactured and I when you talk
to people and I know like people in your
industry will dress it up with a
euphemism and they'll say it's it's
Health Care
to cut off the private parts of a 14 or
15 year old that is not health care that
is mutilation and so when we're standing
up against that
guys office rocker
[Applause]
people who who went through this when
they were minors now they're older and
it's like the biggest regret of their
life they feel like that they were
manipulated I understand there's some
Physicians that are very ideological
about it but the fact is people go
through a lot when they're teenagers you
grow out of it most of the time in these
situations 80 90 percent resolves by the
time you get there Sweden these European
countries that went down this road have
done a big U-turn they said this is not
good uh medical practice and so they
don't do it anymore so all we're doing
is is doing what's right
um the idea that this would have been
something that people would have been it
would have even been controversial even
like 10 years ago would not have been
something that anybody would have said
well you know what's funny is 10 years
ago the rights wasn't obsessed with it
the the treatments have gotten better
but ten years ago the difference was the
right wasn't obsessed with it and in
some senses it was actually a better
process to go through and get the
treatment that people wanted to get and
that they believed was right for them in
consultation with their doctors DeSantis
asked about are you gonna run in 2024 or
not and he says relatively soon he's
going to get on that relatively soon
well look I mean I think that I was
started to get asked about this actually
years ago right but it's like look I I
was I was in my first term as Governor
we were doing good things a lot of the
stuff I was doing that I think put me on
the map was because I was getting
criticized for it especially during
covid turned out he didn't want to be in
the spotlight he was just doing the
right things and people started paying
attention that that Florida handled it
right and then many other things there
but I was like look the end of the day
it was a leader you get things done very
important but you also got to show take
that case to the voters and you got to
be able to get some support on the on
the on the election front and so I felt
very confident going into November 22 we
were going to do very well but uh you
really had to put put up or shut up on
that and so we did that and I think that
that was something that was really
significant so then people have been
asking a lot after the at this is all
him pretending like he never really was
looking to run but everybody just came
to him and they were so impressed but I
also understood that we had this
opportunity here to be able to really
really do a lot of great stuff and I've
always said that we're going to see this
through and that's what we're going to
do you know what happens uh in the
future look people will will get on that
relatively soon I mean there's just you
know you either gotta put up or shut up
on that as well so what's weird is if he
says he's going to see that this through
that suggests that he would stay for the
whole gubernatorial term but clearly if
he's going to run in 2024 that's not
going to happen
um unless with the law change he's
actually going to try to be a functional
governor and right I don't know where
the guy's planning it's all crazy it's
all really really crazy
um and of course that term wouldn't be
over if he became president he would end
up leaving I don't know what he means by
we're gonna see it through uh there was
then um he wrapped up with talking about
cutting off private parts which is a
classic that they now are in love with
repeating over and over again slates are
prohibited doing things like double
mastectomies they prohibited doing
things you know with uh with male
private parts that are very graphic they
prohibited pumping these miners with
puberty blockers just not something that
that it's appropriate so I think those
are appropriate guard rails look there's
some parents that this is something that
that they want to go down that road but
I think a lot of parents you know they
just want what's best for their kid
their kid may be going through something
so then they'll go to a physician and
the physician is pushing this stuff on
the family and and that's just that's
wrong and so we're happy that that we
were able to to do that remember that
they've still not demonstrated to my
satisfaction certainly that Physicians
are pushing things on people
for a lot of these folks explaining
options that exist they say that's a
form of pushing I understand
same activists were upset about the
death penalty for raping the miners
under 12. why are you upset about that
is that really the hill that you want to
die on I think some of these people that
particularly the serial abusers of these
kids I think the only appropriate
punishment is capital punishment in
those situations and kill him he's
saying kill them is he talking about
doctors who is he talking about it's
just just a little bit vague so you
can't be totally sure so we were right
to do that
and we'll continue to continue to do
what's right so all right everybody God
bless thanks so much God bless you
everybody okay yeah we're gonna kill
doctors thank you very much now um the
polling keeps getting worse for DeSantis
it's not dramatically worse this is a
2024 Republican nomination poll and it
actually has a chart you see that the
second line here this DeSantis line it
peaked uh in mid-February and then got
almost back up there in late March but
there's been this pretty significant
decline quite frankly the decline
started right before Trump got arrested
and and then did get arrested
um continuing to kind of stick between
DeSantis was between 23 and 24 for a
while in the primary polling remember
this is against Trump he's now down
between 22 and 23. so the polling's
getting worse not dramatically worse but
it really doesn't seem like this guy has
what it takes and it's so easy to get
under his skin I hope he does run
because I think it's better for the
Democratic nominee and it's worse for
DeSantis and it's worse for Trump we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P
I don't really know what to make of this
call it's a caller who says he's obese
and he's he's called in before and I he
he is obese I believe that part that's
not the joke but he says he identifies
as thin I don't know let's see what you
make of this I don't know if this is
like an anti-trans thing or what no joke
really no joke I am an obese male
but you know what I identify as uh
sin
muscular man okay why well I'm obese
compared to who compared to a sumo
wrestler I am pretty darn thin
so yes I identify as
a thin muscular man even though I am an
obese
person
with metabolic syndrome
why am I saying all of this yeah
what's the difference I really don't
understand the difference
between what
you don't understand the difference
between what and what
a between a trans person expressing
their gender
and an obese person saying they identify
as muscular and then I don't know but if
there's any greater confusion about
trans people than that voicemail I
certainly haven't seen it we've got a
great bonus show for you uh there is a
new poll
which we talked about at the top of the
show from ABC and we talked about the
top level results but there are some
other results that are interesting
including one that shows that under 35
percent of the population right now
believes Joe Biden has the mental
sharpness required for a second
presidential term we will discuss that
will that become a problem the Seattle
Public Library system has launched a
program to allow teens to access books
that have been banned we will discuss
that and lastly in the wake of this
horrifying horrifying shooting in Texas
a Texas lawmaker is lobbying to teach
third graders to do first aid for
gunshot wounds so that if there's a
shooting and one of their classmates
gets shot the third graders who would be
between eight and nine years old would
be prepared to administer gunshot
related first aid this is where we are
in Texas in the United States all of
those stories and more when I am joined
by producer pat on the bonus show oh the
bonus show where you
were you I was as bad
super strong bonus show today I do think
today will make money on the bonus show
last week we took out a day off for
making money on the bonus show but this
week we should do it uh also I have just
been notified that Steve Bannon is now
coming after me so we're going to review
that I'll probably have more for about
that for you either on the bonus show or
tomorrow join pacman.com is the place to
sign up
foreign